yeah you know we really started before
we shut down you know we went through
social distancing elements and those
last four or five days before we shut
down and then as soon as we shut down
you know we started working on what what
could we do to enhance our cleaning
procedures what could we do to enhance
safety and then you know during the
month of March and then the month of
April more information keeps coming out
so it's continued to evolve but you know
I think we worked we worked very closely
with the Gaming Control Board with the
state obviously we're following all CDC
guidelines and what we're trying to do
is either meet or exceed you know all
these guidelines and we're ready I think
our processes are ready to go I would
say probably one of the biggest things
that we're doing is we're bringing in
thermal scanners for all of our doors at
the Golden Gate and the Dean we've had a
good amount of time to practice just
being able to get people in in a in an
orderly fashion it doesn't make a lot of
sense to have people standing outside
for 15 minutes you know and 110 degree
heat when when in fact you know you can
move people through pretty quickly but
but we've been getting people through at
a rate of about one person every about
11.4 seconds so so we think that's
pretty good and we've got seventeen of
them so I think we're gonna be able to
move people through pretty quickly and
and and although it's not required we're
gonna we're gonna open with that and our
thought is it's gonna make make some of
the customers that come inside the D and
the Golden Gate you know maybe feel a
little safer and I think everybody wants
to feel safe but everybody wants to get
out and have a little fun
yeah you know I think one of the one of
the key things that we're going to
implement is we're gonna implement the
fact that we're putting thermal scanners
outside of all of our all of our
entrances so the regulation stipulates
that all hotel guests meet need to go
through a scanner we're gonna do it all
over at all of our hotel doors for
everyone coming in so that's going to be
one one rather significant change for us
versus when we closed and then as far as
the tables go we're gonna have three
people per blackjack table to start with
we're gonna have three people per side
on each side of the dice game so those
are those a couple couple of bigger
things that'll be a little different
than maybe if people were here a year
ago
yeah we're gonna open we're gonna open
with with an element with every other
chair removed and and yet we're gonna
keep them machines on as part of our
safety plan as of this point and the
reason we're doing that is we've been
pretty active we're talking with the
Control Board that it doesn't from our
perspective it really didn't make a lot
of sense that if you have a quarantine
quarantine group or quarantine family
boyfriend/girlfriend husband/wife it
doesn't make sense to split them up
necessarily often they're gonna feel
much more comfortable being next to each
other if they've been quarantined
together for ten weeks so we're gonna
leave the machines on but we're gonna be
pretty active with regards to making
sure people people here to social
distance yeah we just went through that
today so you know we are going to
require that all employees are wearing
eye masks and as far as customers go
we're gonna offer that two to two
customers that come in I expect many
many many people that walk in are gonna
either have their own masks or you know
something with their own logo or our
medically some some type of mask who
they prefer for people that don't have a
mask we will offer them a mask if if
they like if they like a mask so that's
going to be something unique if somebody
if somebody walks up to the table and
asked for a hundred thousand dollar
credit line we will ask him to pull
their mask down just to make sure we
know who were giving the money to
yeah you know I think I think from the
hotel perspective you know I think some
of the cleaning practices not just
really what we're doing but also what
the linen companies around town are
doing and the procedures to maintain to
maintain the safety to mean maintain
when when there are dirty linens that go
out that that they're able to be moved
out in a controlled environment and
things like that so I think it's I think
really in some ways that there's um
there's an awful lot of enhancements
that are that are taking place with
regards to hotel rooms not just in Las
Vegas but around the country and then
when you think about some of the heavy
more heavy touch surface elements such
as a remote control or a house telephone
in your hotel room obviously there's far
more far more cleaning that takes place
at different enhancements that go along
with with a room turn
well I mean I think you know I'm
fortunate and I'm get to be on the board
of the Fremont Street Experience so
we're legally all partners in the
Fremont Street Experience we've met
every every Tuesday to talk through hey
what did you find out do you have a good
did you have a new product did some new
vendor come in so we've all kind of
worked through things that's kind of
like what we always do but I would say
in a time like this you know I've talked
to Matt Matt except Winn often I've
talked to people at Caesars and at MGM
regularly this isn't that this is not a
scenario where it's you know locals are
mesquite or lawful and or downtown strip
or Northern Nevada this is this is
something that's important to everybody
and anything everybody's really work to
work well together I mean I I uh I made
a comment that I I told Matt I go thanks
so much for you know putting out you
know what you thought when would do
based upon your experience in Macau and
that really has helped helped a lot of
Las Vegas out so I think this is a
situation where everybody's everybody's
really worked together
no I mean a casino owners one thing but
I would tell you that I'm you know in my
business career this is this is outside
the scope of what I would have imagined
frankly definitely the most difficult
difficult time in managing a business
and you know we all learned a lot of new
things during this learned learn how to
have conference calls on zoom' or
Microsoft teams often and you know we've
really tried to go out and make sure we
talk to a lot of our employees I want to
make sure they're doing okay and like I
told them I said this on my very first
my very first meeting was probably
around I don't know the 20th of March
and I said the commitment I'll give to
everybody here is I commit that we will
reopen on the first day in the first
minute we can and I thought that was a
big deal back then and it's I still
think it's a big deal that my goal is my
goal was never to really evaluate or
take a position on you know stay closed
be open or anything medical like that I
just wanted to you know devour the
information I was given from the CDC
from our state and then from our Control
Board and once we got to go ahead my my
um my thought was I just want to get
things going and jumpstart things as
much as possible to get all of our
people back as quickly as we can
my message would be would be I mean
everybody has to feel comfortable and
everybody's in a different situation so
there's not a right answer the right
answer is what you feel like but but if
you do feel like you want to get out of
the house and you want to come visit Las
Vegas I would tell you it's probably
safer and cleaner than what you've ever
ever seen before and and I think you
know what's happening with the hotel
casino properties I think we've all
taken it to another level so I think
we're as prepared as we could be there's
been a lot of unknowns in all this but I
think we're as prepared as we could be
and we want to welcome people back to
Las Vegas that's kind of why we did the
flights you know here today and well you
know the one thing we wanted to do is we
wanted to make sure that we we supported
an industry that really got decimated
just like hotels did but frankly worse
than that was the airline industry and
you know Las Vegas is very dependent
upon the drive-in market very dependent
upon locals but also you know the flying
market is critical so when we came up
with this idea we just thought well
let's support the airlines and it helps
Las Vegas at the same time so we thought
if we could reach out to the airlines
and buy by a thousand flights son on
various US airlines that would help them
and it would let them know that you know
us from Las Vegas we're thinking about
them in their industry and at the same
time if we bring people to Vegas you
know it might be good for our business
like I think I said in my video I I hope
in my team hopes you may want to stay at
one of our hotels but if you don't
that's okay too because because if you
want to stay at the Golden Nugget or if
you want to stay at a Twinner Caesars
your Bellagio we got to get people back
to work so it's good for it's good for
our community Las Vegas needs these
customers so we kind of thought that
doing a promotion like this was was
great for Vegas as a whole and yeah that
one of the craziest things was you know
we bought these thousand flights and in
just a few hours we had 5,000 people
look for the flight so the first
thousand we're gone
than 2hours it was crazy so we just put
out another tweet and I had my guys
working on something so we added nine
more cities and a whole bunch of other
flights so so we're having a little bit
of fun with this and I just think it's a
great thing for for Las Vegas
what's my stance on
no I mean we're gonna we're gonna
continue to offer smokey I mean there's
a there's a combination of smoking and
gambling that kind of goes together I
think I think with some of the increased
air flows that you're gonna see in some
in some casinos I think that'll that'll
provide for maybe a better environment
than what we had before and obviously
for some properties that wanted to
minimize smoking or have separated you
know non-smoking sections I think that's
great - I think you're gonna end up
having more consumer choice